[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
als die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
von 59 Jahren ins Leben gerufen wurde da
hieß das Treffen noch ganz unverstellt
wer Kunde Begegnung mit dem Ende des
Kalten Krieges aber entwickelte sich die
Konferenz zu einem internationalen
Diplomaten Speed Dating auf dem nicht
weniger als die Weltordnung diskutiert
wurde im Jahr 1 nach Putins Überfall auf
die Ukraine aber passt wer Kunde
Begegnung plötzlich wieder ganz gut
tatsächlich gab es am Rande des Treffens
Gespräche mit der Rüstungsindustrie und
über dem ganzen Wochenende hin die Frage
wie wehrhaft ist der Westen wirklich
Stefan leifert bilanziert
am Ende wird es fast ausgelassen auf der
Bühne im Münchner Nobelhotel Bayerischer
Hof Mitarbeiter und Chef der
Sicherheitskonferenz feiern das alles
gut gelaufen ist für das hochkarätigste
aber geheim gehaltene Treffen von
München kann man das nicht behaupten
dass sich der US-Außenminister und
Chinas top-diplomat überhaupt noch
trafen ist eine Überraschung Zeichen für
Entspannung ist es nicht
wir machen uns große Sorgen dass China
darüber nachdenkt Waffen an Russland zu
liefern das hätte ernsthafte
Konsequenzen für unsere Beziehungen
in München Rasseln zwei Weltmächte
aneinander während Europa um seinen
Platz in der Welt ringt der Tag in
München offenbart mal wieder wie nackt
Europa bei einer gemeinsamen
Sicherheitspolitik da steht
Russland verfeuert pro Tag so viel
Artillerie Munition wie Europa in einem
Monat produziert und die europäische
Rüstungsindustrie hat ihre Produktion
noch immer nicht hochgefahren wo ist
wirklich das Hindernis
Frankreich Deutschland Polen und andere
haben verstanden dass Europa aufrüsten
muss
an Erkenntnis mangelt es Europa nicht
aber an Umsetzung seit Jahren beklagt
die EU ihre fehlende
sicherheitspolitische Emanzipation von
den USA und fehlende Kooperation
untereinander doch die sogenannte
Verteidigungsunion blieb immer nur
Lippenbekenntnis ich glaube es ist
bisher in den letzten Jahren daran
gescheitert dass es keine Dringlichkeit
gab und es ist auch daran gescheitert
dass jeder der 27 Nationalstaaten am
Ende dann doch sein eigenes Ding machen
wollte die Idee von einer eu-armee hat
mal wieder Konjunktur realistisch ist
sie kaum einheitliches Systeme
gemeinsame Beschaffung wäre ein
bescheidenes Ziel doch selbst da
blockiert Europa sich selbst so bitter
es ist dieser Krieg den Russland
ausgelöst hat er hat uns sehr viel mehr
den Strukturen einer ver teidigungsunion
gebracht weil wir sehr schnell auch
natürlich Peter lernen was ist braucht
und sich selbständig aufzustellen und
hier ist nicht das letzte Wort
gesprochen hier hat die Arbeit gerade
erst begonnen die Sicherheitskonferenz
begann mit dem Ruf selenskis nicht müde
zu werden in der Unterstützung der
Ukraine und sie offenbart nun wie
schwierig das wird
ich glaube es bleibt ein sehr
einheitliches und geschlossenes Signal
zu Unterstützung der Ukraine es bleibt
aber auch die Frage wie diese politisch
bekundete langfristige Unterstützung der
Ukraine technisch operativ umgesetzt
werden kann die Sicherheitskonferenz
kehrt zusammen und offenbart eine Welt
die ihn Blöcke zerfällt Europa ist
geschlossen doch was das Wert ist bleibt
auch nach München beunruhigend offen
der neue Chef der Sicherheitskonferenz
ist Christoph Heusgen zwölf Jahre lang
war er Angela Merkels außenpolitischer
Berater und in dieser Funktion bei allen
Gesprächen zur außen und
Sicherheitspolitik dabei wie zum
Beispiel hier mit Wladimir Putin 2016 in
Berlin und aus München ist er uns jetzt
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Heusgen
ja guten Abend
Sicherheitskonferenz der Name
verpflichtet wie kann denn ein solches
Treffen die Welt sicherer machen wenn
die die sie im Moment unsicher machen
also zum Beispiel Russland und Iran wenn
deren Vertreter gar nicht eingeladen
sind
das fragen viele aber wissen Sie zu
einem Dialog gehören zwei Parteien und
wir sehen gerade das Russland kein
einzigen Abstrich macht an seiner
Maximalposition und dass dies die
Eroberung der Ukraine Russland hat die
Eigenständigkeit die Unabhängigkeit der
Ukraine in Frage gestellt und bis heute
gibt es keine Abstriche und wir können
in München jetzt nicht den unsäglichen
Propaganda reden von dem Außenminister
Lavra Folgen es ist viel wichtiger dass
wir hier Einheit im atlantischen Bündnis
beweisen und dass wir und das haben wir
in dieser Konferenz auch gemacht noch
mal sehr viel weiter ausgreifen Richtung
Afrika Lateinamerika und Asien wir
müssen zusammen stehen wir müssen die
internationale Ordnung die uno-karte da
verteidigen wir müssen zusammenstehen
gegen jemanden der eben das
international reicht mit Füßen tritt und
da war kein Platz für Russland und ich
habe hier auch bei den Teilnehmern an
der Konferenz sehr viel Unterstützung
dafür
gespürt dass wir den
Herrn lavrov nicht hier die Möglichkeit
gegeben haben sich auszudrücken sondern
den Ukrainern die die Möglichkeit hatten
hier noch mal klar da zu stellen wie sie
um ihr Überleben kämpfen die chinesische
allerdings war natürlich auch nicht ganz
Propaganda frei der durfte ja reden
der durfte reden er durfte reden er hat
nicht die Ukraine überfallen und wir
machen es ja auch so bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz dass wir nur ganz
wenige Länder dann nicht einladen es war
wichtig dass China hier war und wir sind
auch froh dass wir als Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz die Grundlage
geboten haben dafür dass der
amerikanische ausmesser und der
chinesische Außenminister sich hier
getroffen haben das ist wichtig dass
München das bietet aber da hoffen wir
eben darauf dass die beiden sich einigen
das ist auch in der
Eskalationsspirale die wir manchmal ein
bisschen sehen zwischen den USA und
China dass wir einen Beitrag Laden dass
da vielleicht ein bisschen
ganze niedriger gehalten wird
richtig ist dass die westliche
Gemeinschaft auf jeden Fall in München
geschlossen aufgetreten ist aber was ist
diese Geschlossenheit eigentlich wert
wenn die Europäer ist noch nicht mal
schaffen 60 einsatzbereite Kampfpanzer
an die Ukraine zu liefern
ja das ist jetzt wirklich absolut
dringlich wissen sie in Deutschland gab
es auch von dem europäischen counther
und von Relation schon im Sommer den
Vorschlag des unter deutscher Führung
sich alle Leopard Nationen also die die
den Panzer haben zusammenkommen dass sie
überlegen wer kann liefern wie können
wir ausbilden wir können wir dann auch
anschließend warten das ist leider nicht
umgesetzt worden jetzt hat man das
erkannt wie wichtig das ist und die hat
Deutschland jetzt die Führung übernommen
das ist ganz wichtig aber wir dürfen
keine Zeit verlieren heute bei der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat der
Außenbeauftragte der Europäischen Union
den Vorschlag gemacht dass wir auch die
munitionsbeschaffung dass wir das auf
europäischer Ebene machen damit wir der
Ukraine schnell helfen können und es
wäre ganz wichtig dass jetzt hier sofort
operiert wird und dass wir das machen
denn die haben die russischen Truppen
machen ihre Fortschritte sie haben eben
selbst auch gesagt wie wichtig das ist
dass die Munition bekommen und hier
müssen wir agieren die europä ische
Union ist bereit dazu und wir müssen
jetzt auch als Deutschland da sofort
mitmachen ist das nicht auch ein Mangel
an deutscher Führung sie haben ja mit
allen Delegationen im Vorfeld der
Konferenz gesprochen was erwartet man
jetzt von Deutschland auch beim
Schmieden dieser panzerkoalition
ja also es wird von allen wirklich
anerkannt dass Deutschland was für eine
180 Grad Wendung gemacht hat wir haben
vor einem Jahr kurz vor dem Einmarsch
hat hier auch noch die Außenministerin
gesagt wir liefern keine Waffen jetzt
liefern wir Waffen wir liefern Panzer
alle erkennen an was wir hier so eine
solche Wendung gemacht haben aber wir
dürfen keine Zeit verlieren und der
Bundeskanzler hat ja hier auch sehr
überzeugend geredet hat gesagt wir
unterstützen die Ukraine wir kennen wir
sehen wie wichtig es ist dass die
Ukraine das den Krieg nicht verliert wir
müssen unterstützen wir müssen operativ
jetzt alles tun das muss schnell gehen
der neue Verteidigungsminister sieht
glaube ich die Dringlichkeit aber es
darf keine Zeit verloren werden man muss
jetzt auch im täglichen Rhythmus daran
arbeiten und muss es wirklich schnell
machen wie gesagt ist sehr viel
Vertrauen in Deutschland das habe ich
hier gespürt aber es ist aus außerdem
sehr viel Ungeduld dabei in München ging
es dieses Wochenende ja auch um mögliche
Friedensinitiativen sie haben 2015 schon
mal mit Putin Nächte lang über Frieden
verhandelt damals ging es um das Minsker
Abkommen das Russland wenig später
gebrochen hat unter welchen
Voraussetzungen sehen sie überhaupt noch
dass man noch mal mit Putin reden könnte
ja wir haben in der Tat vielen Dank dass
Sie daran erinnern wir haben nächtelang
zusammengerissen wir hatten einen
diplomatischen Weg wir haben das
metzgerabkommen was ermöglicht hätte
dazu dass die Ukraine ihre territorial
Integrität wiedergewonnen hätten für die
besetzten Gebieten war eine gewisse
Autonomie vorgesehen wir wollten es
umsetzen wir haben wirklich über Wochen
Monate Jahre verhandelt die
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat das getan
das alles zunichte gemacht jetzt gibt es
auf diesem Weg nichts wir müssen das wir
müssen die Ukraine stärken und wenn die
wenn die Russen einsehen dass sie
militärisch nicht weiterkommen dann kann
man noch mal überlegen dass man eine Art
mindeste Abkommen macht aber diesmal
müssen wir die der Ukraine auch die
Versicherung geben
Sicherheitsgarantien geben das nicht
Russland wenn es sich auf einmal anders
überlegt dass dann nicht Russland noch
mal die Ukraine überfallen kann so wie
es jetzt vor einem Jahr gemacht hat
Christoph war das Leiter der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch
vielen Dank
der amerikanische Außenminister Toni
blinken ist direkt von der
Sicherheitskonferenz in die Türkei
gereist um sich dort ein Bild der Lage
zu machen und weitere Hilfslieferungen
anzukündigen ganz anders die Situation
im Erdbebengebiet jenseits der Grenze in
Syrien der syrische Diktator Bascha al
Assad hat bisher nur wenig Hilfe ins
Land gelassen und noch weniger in die
Gebiete die von den Aufständischen
kontrolliert werden es hat missbraucht
die humanitäre Hilfe um sich selbst als
barmherzigen Retter zu inszenieren
unsere Reporterin golini atai hat es bis
nach afrin geschafft
gäbe es die Kinder nicht denen er helfen
muss er würde nicht mehr auf den Beinen
stehen sagte er
malekresse die Pfleger im Krankenhaus
von afrin schaut auf die neuen Zelte in
seiner Stadt zählte nicht für
Kriegsflüchtlinge sondern für die
Überlebenden des Lebens
drinnen liegt der dreijährige Tarik 48
Stunden war er verschüttet er hat seine
ganze Familie verloren und ein Bein aber
seit heute liegt er nicht mehr auf der
Intensivstation ständig erzählt Pfleger
Malik Rufe der Junge nach seiner
Schwester
der Kleine ist psychisch am Boden wir
versuchten alles um Psychologen hierher
zu bringen wie Sie sehen antwortete
nicht seit Tagen reagiert er nicht mehr
die Frühchen konnte der Pfleger retten
als er den Raum betrat nach dem Beben
waren die Inkubatoren hin und her
geschleudert worden die Babys erzählt er
hatten keinen Sauerstoff mehr waren blau
im Gesicht ohne die Erste Hilfe während
sie gestorben
wie viele Kinder hätten wir retten
können wenn wir Suchhunde wenn wir
Bergungsteams aus dem Ausland gehabt
hätten fragt sich der Pfleger jeden Tag
kennen das ja dass die internationale
Gemeinschaft und hängen lässt es ist
normal keine Hilfe zu bekommen wir haben
uns daran gewöhnt und selbst irgendwie
zu managen aber all diese Leben ich
wünschte ich hätte sie retten können
überall im Krankenhausgebäude sind Risse
angeblich sei nicht einsturzgefährdet
wird ihnen gesagt aber jede Nacht bebt
die Erde erneut jede Nacht hat Schwester
roraya Hamid wieder Angst in einem
humanitären Krisengebiet wie Nordwest
Syrien sei jede Katastrophe um ein
Vielfaches tödlicher
wir haben hier einen Mangel an Ärzten an
Ausrüstung an Medizin an Scannern wir
können keinem der erdbebenpatienten
alles Erforderliche anbieten
viele Kilometer weiter südlich bei iglib
in einem Lager für Kriegsflüchtlinge
eine syrische Gruppe teilt Hilfe aus
Brennmaterial zum Heizen einige
Erdbebenopfer haben sich hierher
gerettet
er sprang aus dem zweiten Stock die Füße
sind gebrochen
seine Familie brachte ihn hierher seine
Mutter und fünf Jahre Verwandte
beerdigten Sie hier das Erdbeben und der
erneute Verlust seines Hauses hat sein
Kriegstrauma reaktiviert warum habe ich
kein normales Leben fragte er sich
mein größter Wunsch dass alle Länder der
Welt alles tun um uns syrische
vertriebene zurück nach Hause zu bringen
dass sie uns von diesem
unterdrückerischen Regime
ohne ein metallimplantat wird er
vielleicht nie wieder laufen können ein
zweiter Traum der wahrscheinlich nie
wahr werden wird
und wenn sie spenden wollen können Sie
das tun beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe auf folgendes konto.de
65-100 400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien informationen auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-text auf
Seite 890
und bei uns macht jetzt Heinz Wolf
weiter mit den Nachrichten und die
beginnen mit dem Streit in der
Ampelkoalition ja da sind im Zuge der
Vorbereitung des neuen Haushalts die
Kabinettskollegen Habeck von den Grünen
und Lindner von der FDP
aneinandergeraten im Interview mit der
ZDF-Sendung Berlin direkt sagte der
FDP-Fraktionsvorsitzende Dürre dazu es
geht darum gemeinsam das vereinbarte
umzusetzen wir sollten jetzt nicht
langsamer werden wir sollten eher
schneller in der Modernisierung werden
denn die alte große Koalition habe
vieles liegen gelassen
drei Jahre nach dem rassistischen
Anschlag von Hanau wurde heute an die
Oper erinnert in der Hanauer Innenstadt
kamen hunderte zu einer Kundgebung
zusammen zuvor hatten sich
Hinterbliebene und Freunde der Opfer auf
dem Friedhof versammelt an der
Gedenkveranstaltung nahmen auch und es
Innenministerin Fräser und
hessensministerpräsident reinteil
2020 hatte ein 43-jähriger deutscher
neuen Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
getötet danach erschoss er seine Mutter
und sich selbst
das Sozialverband VdK fordert zur
besseren Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und
Pflege einen Rechtsanspruch auf
Tagespflege vergleichbar mit dem
Rechtsanspruch auf einen Kitaplatz vor
der Präsidentin Bentele sagte der Bild
am Sonntag 2,2 Millionen pflegende
Angehörige arbeiteten derzeit nicht oder
in Teilzeit dieses Potenzial liege brach
im Tarifkonflikt bei der Deutschen Post
geht es nach den Warnstreiks jetzt um
die Frage ob unbefristete
Arbeitsniederlegungen kommen die
Gewerkschaft wäre die beginnt morgen mit
der Urabstimmung bislang hatte es
zeitlich befristete Warnstreiks gegeben
und vor gut einer Woche dann das
Scheitern nach der dritten
Verhandlungsrunde wäre die fordert eine
Entgelterhöhung von 15% bei einer
Laufzeit des Tarifvertrages von 12
Monaten
nächste Woche also jährt sich Putins
Überfall auf die Ukraine seit einem Jahr
tobt der Krieg in Europa eine
Zeitenwende Christian Sievers und Alisa
jung haben sich aus diesem Anlass
aufgemacht um Menschen zu porträtieren
deren Leben sich durch den Krieg radikal
verändert hat Politiker Manager Militärs
und ganz normale Leute wie die Ärztin
Hanna stojak die von einem Tag auf den
anderen aus der großstadtregion
flüchtete und jetzt mit ihrer Tochter
versucht in Mülheim an der Mosel Fuß zu
fassen den Ehemann und den älteren Sohn
musste sie wegen des Ausreiseverbots in
der Ukraine zurücklassen und Hanna und
ihre Tochter Olga kämpfen täglich darum
dazu zu gehören
stehen und drehen und los und stehen und
drehen und die Kommandos von Trainer
Bernd verstehen längst nicht alle Tonen
verbindet sagt er aber ohne Olga käme er
nicht weiter sie ist nicht nur ass am
Reck sondern dolmetscht auch für die
anderen hier aus der Ukraine dabei war
die Sprache auch für sie gerade noch so
fremd wie viel Deutsch sprichst du denn
jetzt so am Tag normalerweise
erstmal fünf Stunden Schule und ich
brauche meine Freundin mit meiner Mama
manchmal auch Deutsch ehrlich obwohl du
eigentlich mit dir Ukraine sprechen
könntest Wörter
viermal pro Woche Halt finden in der
Turnhalle für ein neues Leben weil das
alte nicht mehr existiert und das gilt
nicht nur für die Tochter hätten sie das
gedacht vor einem Jahr als sie fliehen
mussten sie mal heute hier sitzen in der
Sporthalle in Rheinland-Pfalz
nein
ich habe keine
konnte oder Leute in dieser Ort
und zwar einfach so eine Million
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine leben hier
in Deutschland wo ist sie hin verschlägt
und wie es ihnen ergeht hängt oft vom
Zufall ab was ist saporisch Region
so viele Erinnerungen ans eigene Haus
den Garten mit 16 Sorten Rosen die
Eltern der Mann der Bruder alle jetzt
weit weg mutig und flexibel die
deutsch-vokabeln an der Wand wie eine
Beschreibung ihrer Lage
Mami was können wir tun wenn Krieg kommt
hatte die Tochter gefragt wir setzen uns
ins Auto und fahren nach Westen hatte
die Mutter geantwortet es sollte stark
klingen nach einem Plan so wie Hanna
stojak für alles einen Plan hat auch
jetzt noch
weil ich möchte selbstständig sein ja
ich möchte nicht mit
soziale Geld das ist wichtig weil das
ist eine große Teil von meiner Leben
meine Job meine Arbeit guten Tag die
Kinder die Frau Dr steuert die kommt ja
ab und zu und die begleitet uns hier und
wir wollen sie heute noch mal
kontrollieren wie es Ihnen heute
gegangen ist ja in der Ukraine war sie
zehn Jahre lang Ärztin in einer
Kinderklinik jetzt lebt sie von
Sozialhilfe und macht Praktikum bei
einem Hausarzt versuchen Sie auch bitte
noch einmal zu husten der würde sie am
liebsten gleich einstellen als
Nachfolgerin wenn er in Rente geht
wurzelreizung auf Ukrainisch
ukrainischer
[Musik]
doch dr stojak muss noch womöglich Jahre
Geduld haben bis sie hier wirklich
arbeiten darf kaum Angebote für Kurse
und Prüfungen und viel Unsicherheit
welche Arztausbildung bei uns anerkannt
wird ich würde mir wünschen dass die
bürokratischen Hindernisse schnell dazu
überwinden wären denn die finde ich für
uns in Deutschland eigentlich erbärmlich
Hanna stojak spürt ohne ständiges
kämpfen tut sich wenig andere
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine im selben
Ort haben es weit weniger gut geschafft
sie leben seit Monaten in einem
ausrangierten Gasthof Zimmer zu dritt
auf 20 Quadratmeter
ich weiß nicht wie kann ich helfen auch
für eine die versucht alles im Griff zu
behalten ist es manchmal zu viel träumen
sie manchmal von der Ukraine
absolut
von was träumen sie dann
von meiner Eltern meine Sohn
ich will doch stark sein sagt sie für
meine Tochter
die ist angekommen in der Schule feiert
Olga ihren ersten Karneval
und nächste Woche tritt sie an im
Turnwettkampf um den moselpokal
und dafür drücken wir die Daumen für den
moselpokal und machen hier ebenfalls
weiter mit Nachrichten vom Sport und
Heinz Wolf zu Fußball-Bundesliga da hat
Union Berlin den Sprung an die
Tabellenspitze verpasst das 0:0 heute
gegen Schalke hat nicht gereicht um die
Bayern ganz vorne abzulösen Borussia
Dortmund gewann gegen Hertha BSC 4:1 bei
Leverkusen verlor zwei zu drei gegen
Mainz
das letzte Weltcup springen vor der
nordischen Ski-WM haben Karl Geiger und
Andreas Wellinger gewonnen in rasendorf
Rumänien siegten sie im sogenannten
super-team-wettbewerb vor den Duos aus
Slowenien und Österreich
bei der Biathlon-WM in Oberhof sind die
deutschen Männer ohne eine Medaille
geblieben beim Abschluss heute gingen
die deutschen Frauen im Massenstart auch
mehr aus Sprint Weltmeisterin Denise
Hermann Wick kam mit fünf schießfedern
auf Platz 24 Start
[Applaus]
erwarten Sie an dieser Stelle eher ein
niveaugefälle das sind nicht meine Worte
sondern die von danger denn alias Daniel
Pongratz dem Liedermacher Rapper und
Aktivisten aus Aachen dem Selbstironie
kein bisschen fremd ist während des
Corona lockdowns hatte er keine Lust
Klavier zu üben und komponierte
stattdessen ein ganzes Album das Niveau
hat und Erfolg nächsten Sonntag bekommt
ihr nun den Deutschen Kleinkunstpreis
verliehen klingt klein ist aber einer
der großen deutschen Kunstpreise Kai
Felix Jochens hat danger denn getroffen
wenn Musik ein Spiegel der Seele ist
kann ein Mensch viel damit aussagen
[Musik]
gute Nacht
der erste schlechte wird zerfahren zu
Staub wir waren zu Arschloch kehren das
nicht zurück aus den wir alle eins
gekommen sind und jetzt die gute heute
nicht es bleibt noch Zeit für dich wenn
du willst schlaf doch heut bei mir
Daniel Pongratz alias danger denn
[Musik]
39 Jahre alt gebürtig aus Aachen einer
der komponiert obwohl er keine Noten
lesen kann
also ich komponiere er haptisch also
wirklich ich erspiel mir so Sachen und
merkt mir die Bewegungsabläufe ich gucke
dann auch selten auf die Klaviatur und
wenn wir irgendwas gefällt spiele ich
das so lange im Kreis dass ich mir das
merken kann
danger dan hat sich in die Riege der
deutschen spitzenpoeten getextet obwohl
er mehrfach von Schulen flog kein Abi
machte oder Studium Abschluss und vor
schon vorgezeichneten wegen stets
geflohen ist Lauf davon lauft davon
lauft davon
lauft davon so schnell du kannst bevor
sie dich bekommen
[Musik]
ständig auf Tour zu sein passt da
vielleicht ganz gut solo und als Teil
der hip-hop-formation Antilopen Gang
danger Dance musikalische Entwicklung
vom Rap zum deutschen Chanson dabei
gleich geblieben die immer klare Haltung
gegen Rechts besonders deutlich empfiehl
diskutierten Titel das ist alles von der
Kunstfreiheit gedeckt
darauf verschissen zu sein weil
diskutiert mit dem nicht Party
Geschichte gezeigt man vertrauen
weil der Verfassungsschutz aufgebaut
haben weil die Polizei doch selbst war
weil sie nur Italo gefesselt
wenn du friedlich gegen die Gewalt ist
das
letzte Mal zusammen bleibt
diese meditationsstelle im Kontext des
ganzen jedes angucken das ist meine
Erfahrung und das ist immer wieder
Momente gibt wo eben die Polizei und die
Staatsanwaltschaft das nicht schafft
militanten Neonazis nachzukommen und
wenn sie das machen was in ihr
Tagesgeschäft ist nämlich Angst
Schrecken hast und Gewalt zu verbreiten
dann muss man sich den in den Weg
stellen und das muss man glaube ich auch
mit allen Mitteln
so denkt und fühlt er also dieser danger
dan und serviert es uns in seiner Musik
bestimmt wird das nicht allen schmecken
aber das soll es offensichtlich ja auch
gar nicht
zeigen mich öffne einen Set das ist
alles von mir alles klar alles klar
alles klar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und hier kommt jetzt für sie der heute
journal Ausblick mit dem was nächste
Woche wichtig wird zusammengestellt von
Eric illen sehr
[Musik]
in einen Moskauer Messezentrum hat
Präsident Putin für Dienstag beide
Kammern des Parlaments eingeladen zu
seiner Rede an die Nation angesichts der
internationalen Sanktionen klagen viele
Russen über die wirtschaftlich
schwierige Lage wenig später im Innenhof
des Warschauer Schlosses wird
US-Präsident beiden eine Gegenrede
halten auch ein Treffen mit östlichen
NATO-Partnern soll es geben
deutschlandweit sind Veranstaltungen
geplant zum Jahrestag des Kriegsbeginns
am Freitag Bundespräsident Steinmeier
hat eingeladen ins Schloss Bellevue
Außenministerin baerburg Tag der New
York mit der unvollversammlung die mit
einer neuen Resolution Russland
zurückzug auffordern will
ein neuer Präsident ein neues Parlament
die Bürger Nigerias haben am Samstag die
Wahl allerdings warnen Beobachter vor
Gewalt denn alle drei Bewerber haben
unterschiedliche ethnische religiöse und
regionale Zugehörigkeiten
Nigerias die größte Volkswirtschaft und
das bevölkerungsreichste Land Afrikas
bis Samstag ist Berlin noch auf
Bärenjagd dann steht fest der Gold holt
und wer Silber 19 Filme sind offiziell
im Rennen darunter auch fünf deutsche
bei den Internationalen Filmfestspielen
in Berlin
und noch die Wetteraussichten zum Start
in die neue Woche im Norden gibt es
morgen viele Wolken im Nordosten Regen
dabei weht der Wind stark an den Küsten
stürmisch im Süden ist es freundlich und
trocken die Temperatur erreicht 8 bis 16
Grad der Dienstag wird im Süden sonnig
dabei ist es mit bis zu 17 Grad
ungewöhnlich mild im Norden fällt etwas
Regen am Mittwoch ist es im Westen am
Donnerstag überall unbeständig und kühl
das war es von uns an diesem Sonntag
hier geht's weiter mit der Reihe Mord in
Genua und einem Fall für Petra delikato
und um 0 0 25 gibt es dann die nächste
heute Express
und morgen erwarten Sie hier Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali Ihnen einen
schönen Abend tschüss
[Musik]